alors on vous parle d'une première ce
soir la nasa a découverte une planète
hors du système solaire d'une taille
comparable à la terre et où il pourrait
y avoir de la vie où michel rochon est
là pour écouter mais les leçons
mystérieuse découverte michel on le
présente là cette planète on l'appelle
la kepler ou l'autonomie laqué place 186
certes c'est son nom et on parle là
d'une cousine à la terre ou et d'une
cousine en fait c'est cette équipe là là
c'est la planète numéro milles environ
qu'il découvre la d'exoplanètes celle
est intéressante parce qu'elle a à peu
près juste 10% de plus grosse que la
terre la planète en question et alain
soler comparable aux notes qui
malheureusement la moitié moins en moins
volumineux mais elle est beaucoup plus
près que la terre de notre soleil
alors ce qui fait que la température
parce que sous des conditions 1 il faut
une planète solide avec possiblement de
l'eau on voudrait bien et un peu de gaz
et il faut que la distance entre entre
la planète et son son soleil soit elle
connaît des températures comme on est
ici alors entre -10 et b + 30 disons
pour que levi puisse la vie que l'on
connaît puisse se prendre naissance
bon comment les scientifiques de la nasa
elles ont réussi à découvrir cette
nouvelle planète parce qu'elle est très
très loin de chez nous oui en fait
qu'elle prendrait si on avait un avion
on voulait se rendre là ça prendrait un
milliard d'années
c'est un très très long voyage
alors c'est un télescope spatial qui
existe depuis 2009 qui s'appelle kepler
et qui regardent le ciel ne fait qu'une
chose c'est de regarder pour des
différences de lumière dans des étoiles
à rossi de façon périodique
on voit que la lumière aussi ça veut
dire qu'une planète qui fait le tour et
quand elle passe devant elle alors oui
c'est ça allait sombrer alors c'est ce
genre de mesures là et avec les mesures
qu'ils ont il croit qu'il y en croit
qu'il y aurait 40 milliards de planètes
habitables juste dans notre propre
galaxie la voie lactée et on sait qu'il
ya des milliards de galaxies
donc lhi scientifiques se posent
actuellement la question il pense qu'il
y aurait des propos si ble ment des
formes de vie sur d'autres planètes de
façon presque certaine
vu le nombre astronomique de ces de ses
terres possible sur d'autres c'est toi
écoutez on va réfléchir à la voulez bien
vous allez loin j'étais rendu très loin
merci beaucoup mieux c'est beaucoup
voire inquiète